[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale avec tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 8
octobre tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la commanderie a joué les
prolongations samedi soir le site
d'elancourt participer à la nuit blanche
opération culturelle lancée à paris et
jusque tard dans la nuit les visiteurs
ont pu profiter d'une exposition et de
spectacles d'artistes du territoire une
soirée placée sous le signe du corps
humain il doit relier saint cyr l'école
à saint germain en laye en 30 minutes le
tram 13 doit être mise en service en
2021 est les travaux de la ligne ont
officiellement démarré vendredi
inauguration en présence de la
présidente de région valérie pécresse 4
millions de voyageurs par an devrait
emprunter ce nouveau réseau et puis ce
dimanche c'est la deuxième édition du
salon de la rénovation énergétique
l'événement se tient à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux et les
particuliers pourront trouver toutes les
réponses à leurs projets de rénovation à
d'habitat nous en parlons avec notre
invité tiffany buso autres invités dans
ce journal
pierre cojan président de la fédération
française du bâtiment et des yvelines
pour évoquer un autre salon tech bat
60,18 ce vendredi à saint rémy les
chevreuse ils étaient nombreux à lui
rendre un dernier hommage samedi
charles aznavour a été inhumé au
cimetière de montfort l'amaury le
chanteur est décédé le 1er octobre
reposera dans le caveau familial qu'il
venait visiter régulièrement auparavant
et des dizaines d'habitants et de fans
se sont réunis place de l'église le
cortège funéraire a été applaudi au
passage un emmenez-moi a même été
entonnés et micros tendus aux personnes
présentes pour cet hommage par mélanie
poké chère en france depuis 17 ans je
connais un poteau
charles aznavour je connais pas trop les
parents là afin d'aller chassot javad
oji coco on aimait beaucoup six chansons
et puis que je suis mon fort l'amaury un
grand chanteur à pau est gêné j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est toute ma jeunesse
c'est un grand monsieur et la génération
d'un moment qu'il l'aimait beaucoup et
que je les ai entendus dans toute mon
enfance pour ça que j'avais envie
d'accompagner les derniers sa dernière
demeure c'est très important parce que
il est né la même année que mon papa et
j'ai une principaux mon papa qui est
toujours en vie beaucoup aimé ce
chanteur ses chansons et puis moi je
suis dit si je savais qu'il aimait
beaucoup venir ici au masters qui est
encore plus jeune que moi est vraiment à
koné ses chansons connaissait texte on a
baigné dedans depuis tout petit donc
avant c'était important d'être là
aujourd'hui
la commanderie a donc fait durer le
plaisir ce samedi elle participer à la
nuit blanche une opération culturelle
initiée sur paris et jusqu'à minuit le
site d'elancourt a accueilli curieuse et
passionnée autour d'artistes du
territoire et autour aussi d'une
exposition
retour sur cette soirée avec mélanie
poté 21h elle brigue et pour accueillir
le public
pour sa première soirée sous son nouveau
nom la commanderie donner au public des
étoiles plein les yeux en faisant une
blanche une manifestation nationale pour
faire reconnaître tout ce qui est dans
le domaine de la culture
les acteurs du territoire qui sont en
résidence chez nous mais qui en même
temps développe dans leur parti dans
leur arrêt tout qui développe ce que
représente l'art de vivre il
le territoire de 50 à une soirée placée
sous le signe du corps humain du
mouvement
un corps humain qui devient
constellation avec sa nouvelle
installation
l'artiste maillot est pas doué entraîne
au coeur de la voûte céleste
rumeur existe parce que l'être et là au
coeur et interagit avec elle ce ce qui
m'intéresse parce que elle est toujours
renouvelées elles se comportent de façon
différente en fonction des comportements
du pub et c'est vraiment l'intention de
créer les corps stellaire c'est avec la
structure dans notre squelette qui est
détecté par caméra infrarouge arriver à
ce que chacun crée sa propre
constellation et qu'elles soient
enregistrées dans un dans un ciel étoilé
virtuel cette nuit blanche était aussi
l'occasion de lancer la nouvelle
exposition de l'atelier des sciences
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 25
novembre autres nuits celle du droit qui
se déroulait la semaine dernière à
versailles chaque 4 octobre date de
l'anniversaire de la constitution de
1958 on célèbre le droit et pour la
deuxième édition est lu vs qu organiser
déclamation conférences et débats dans
la symbolique salle du jeu de paume du
château de versailles
maryline iapichino et michael et demi
d'euros
[Musique]
il est de 130 ans dans cette même salle
les députés du tiers état ont fait le
serment de ne pas se séparer avant
l'élaboration de la toute première
constitution française
pour cette deuxième édition de la nuit
du droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin a décidé de mettre à l'honneur
un texte fondateur
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de 1789 on a tous
l'impression de connaître la déclaration
à grenoble et du citoyen et finalement
on se rend compte que en le lisant le
relisant il est assez mystérieux j'ai
envie de dire même que tous les juristes
ne le connaissent pas si bien que ça et
nous nous avons choisi deux
de travailler sur ce texte et de le
présenter au public pour mieux le faire
connaître
trois étudiants ont travaillé durant
plusieurs semaines pour déclamer ce
fameux texte face au public
vous retrouvez dans cette salle pour cet
événement est de pouvoir d'éclat mais
ici c'est vraiment du sens pour moi et
c'est une grande chance ça représente un
texte fondateur qui qui est nécessaire
en fait toujours de revenir à ce texte
il donne des droits aux citoyens et
c'est vraiment la figure même du citoyen
français
la soirée s'est poursuivie avec des
conférences des débats en deux actes
autour de la déclaration
cette dimension de transmission de la
mémoire et des valeurs est tout à fait
essentiel est la présence de jeunes en
est un symbole donc tu m'aides intermède
musical la nuit du droit à la salle du
jeu de paume affiché complet à
l'information a été officialisée
aujourd'hui par la préfecture des
yvelines
les élections municipales partielles à
coignières se tiendront bien le dimanche
25 novembre organisée suite à la
démission du maire jean-pierre sevestre
en septembre et de plusieurs élus
le scrutin doit désigner les 27
conseillers municipaux et les deux
conseillers communautaires de saint
quentin en yvelines
un éventuel deuxième tour se déroulerait
le 2 décembre
si ce n'est pas encore le cas les coins
rien ont jusqu'au 15 novembre pour
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales de
la commune
un salon pour les professionnels du btp
tech bat 78 se déroule ce vendredi c'est
au domaine de saint paul à saint rémy
les chevreuse sur place une cinquantaine
d'exposants pour aborder les techniques
nouveaux produits et solutions
innovantes en matière de bâtiment c'est
un rendez vous organisé par la ffb 78
avec nous un plateau son président
pierre cojan bonsoir bonsoir la ffb 68
c'est bien sûr la fédération française
du bâtiment des yvelines alors avant de
présenter ce salon comment se porte le
secteur du bâtiment
en ce mois d'octobre en ce mois
d'octobre
on a eu une année qui a démarré
pas trop mal on a des carnets à peu près
plein mais on s'inquiète un peu pour
l'avenir l'hiver arrive et c'est un peu
les commandes sont un peu légère arriver
c'est un peu d'inquiétude de nos
adhérents alors les enjeux pour le monde
du bâtiment aujourd'hui et c'est en lien
d'ailleurs avec ce salon tech bats et de
regarder vers l'avenir c'est ça c'est
s'adapter à la longue ça avec nos deux
bureaux les conseils d'administration on
a nos adhérents qui ont du mal au jour
le jour à voir ce qui se passe parce que
c'est tout va très vite donc on a
ordonné ce salon là pour les leur
ferveur un peu ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui l'évolution d'aujourd'hui et
surtout de demain c'est demain qu'il va
voir il va falloir se mettre un peu à la
page donc on a salon avec 47 exposants
et les gens qui vont être organisées par
nos partenaires avec tous les produits
nouveaux on a les drones dans l'est de
l'île ronde en à l'intelligence
artificielle on y arrive on allait
maison connectée les et là je pense on
organise 14 mini conférences qui vont
être dixième ronde je crois sur trois
heures sur le réseau est très rare
présente à la fin et je pense que là on
l'a pour l'instant on a pas mal de gens
qui doivent réunir je pense on compte
sur un bon nombre entre 350 500
personnes à venir alors vous le disiez
sur le pourquoi organiser ce salon c'est
aussi la mission de la ffb 78 d'être
dans un rôle d'information entre les
professionnels mais nos nos adhérents à
travers nos partenaires qui sont nos
fournisseurs et on leur demande de ne
présentait pas des produits qu'on les
produits nouveaux et bah ils ont tous
répondu à l'appel 47 exposants c'est
c'est comme ça c'est important
ces entreprises yvelinoise du bâtiment
est ce qu'elles ont pris totalement le
tournant du 21e siècle elles sont encore
un bon ils ont attendu c'est quand il ya
une crise qu un piètre duré dix ans et
quand il est là le redémarrage est et
tout le monde attend dès la reprise on
l'a redit non sauf au patent il faut
s'adapter
et là je pense que tout le monde est
ravi de cette décision et tout le monde
être présents le 12 octobre on compte
sur plein de monde
il ya les nouveaux enjeux l'enjeu
environnemental forcément c est
primordial aujourd'hui de s'adapter avec
son temps on n'a pas le choix face on
sature été très vite et là ça va de plus
en plus vite alors vous disiez sur place
sur à 47 exposants quelle technique
alors on va pas détailler toute l'offre
mais quelle technique quelle solution
pourra découvrir sur place
on va voir le le drone avec les pouvoirs
sofia sion didier que les drom la maison
connectée le
l'intelligence artificielle on y arrive
donc les gens falloir expliquer en
commencé mais qu'ils apprennent et s'ils
se mettent pas dans le jeu dans le
chemin si je suis pas le train ils vont
adresser ce bord de la route
et c'est parce qu'on vous est ce que
nous adhérons me tiens on veut les
soigner et vous disiez ensuite un cycle
de conférences on pourra voir là plein
d'informations 2000 conférences partout
sur les pâtures qui mangent des odeurs
on a les sujets variés c'est très varié
c'est intéressant et chaque exposant se
fait fort d'amener les détectives de m
alors il y aura aussi des des remises de
prix en fin de journée en profiter pour
mettre les remises aux prix audi
d'apprentis qui ont été sélectionnés on
a aussi de prix d'innovation bontinck
qui était distribué par technal dans
l'ouest méthane est un autre qui
s'occupait de ravalement
et avec les techniques énergétiques donc
on fait un plaisir de les mettre à
l'honneur ce jour là le plus quels sont
vos espérances pour vendredi un maximum
de participants on à 3,52 devenu alors
on a aussi ce jour là comme si c'est les
coulisses du bâtiment
on a profité de faire venir cinq
collèges on en a 200 jeunes qui vont
venir de 13h à 15h pour leur expliquer
un petit peu ce qu'est le bâtiment donc
là c'est si le métier nouveau dock sais
pas et je pense que ça va plaire en
revanche le bâtiment aujourd'hui 100
most fébrilement ils ont du mal on les
gens essaient de faire sans embaucher
mais on voudrait que ça embauche ou
travailler autrement et on a aussi
on a eu hier une nouvelle important dans
la cinquantaine d'ingénieurs qui vient
de l'issat de strasbourg qui se joignent
à nous donc c'est sympa merci pierre
cojan d'avoir été avec nous vous êtes le
président de la fédération française du
bâtiment d'éliminer ce salon tech bat 78
c'est ce vendredi au domaine de saint
paul à saint rémy les chevreuse avant de
parler d'un autre salon à notre salon
qui parle d'habitat c'est un projet très
attendu par les yvelinois les travaux du
tram 13 sont engagés la ligne promet
notamment un temps de parcours de
seulement 30 minutes entre saint germain
en laye saint cyr l'école vendredi
plusieurs élus ont inauguré les travaux
d'infrastructures du site de maintenance
et de remisage elle les précisions avec
ce sujet de manon varaldo et michael et
demi d'euros la première pierre du tram
13 a été déposée cette ligne de tram
actuellement en travaux relie saint cyr
à saint germain une seconde phase de
travaux prolongera la ligne du tram 13
de saint germain à achères un projet
attendu par les yvelinois 4 millions de
voyageurs par emprunteront cette ligne
qui entrera en correspondance avec leur
verser et les transilien à l n et u
nous avions vraiment l'impression d'être
abandonnés au niveau du réseau des
transports en commun c'est bien beau
d'avoir tous les transports qui vont
avec ce réseau en étoile que nous
connaissons mais qui passe par le centre
c'est-à-dire paris et de ne pas avoir de
relation de banlieue à banlieue
le tram train circulera de 6h à minuit
en semaine et le samedi et de 6h30 à 22
heures les dimanches et jours fériés
une façon de désengorger les yvelines et
limiter les embouteillages avec une
ligne soucieuse de son environnement
nous avons droit aussi à des transports
écologiques propre silencieux et qui
nous permettent de plus prendre nos
voitures et de plume nous retrouver dans
des embouteillages monstres donc ce
tramway la région la sauver la porter à
bout de bras
on enfile ans plus de la moitié c'est un
tramway qui va permettre de résoudre
notamment la problématique des
embouteillages à saint germain en laye
et c'est un tramway qui se poursuivra
jusqu à poissy achères
donc il ya aussi une dimension sociale
parce que ça permettra aux habitants de
la vallée de la seine de venir
travailler à saint germain en laye à
versailles
comptant niveau la durée du chantier du
tram 13 est estimé à 4 ans pour une mise
en service en 2021 nouveau salon et
nouvel invité avec moi emplettes au
tiffany buso bonsoir vous êtes en charge
de l'organisation du salon de la
rénovation énergétique la deuxième
édition de cet événement se tient ce
dimanche à la ferme du manet de montigny
le bretonneux
après la première édition de l'an passé
c'est la deuxième édition pourquoi
proposer à nouveau ce salon belle
énergie en fait nous avons eu donc 250
visiteurs donc ce qui était en fait
largement au dessus de ce qu'on avait
espéré
du coup ça montre fait qu'il ya vraiment
une demande et qui a un besoin des
particuliers de se renseigner sur la
rénovation énergétique
du coup bah on a lancé une deuxième
édition pour les personnes qui n'ont pas
pu venir les dernières est également il
y aura une spécificité par rapport à
l'année dernière c'est à dire que saint
quentin en yvelines a réalisé une
thermographie aérienne
donc en fait ça permet depuis un
hélicoptère en fait de survoler les
douze communes de l'agglomération et
ensuite c'est interprété ou qu'il ya une
caméra infrarouge et c'est interprété
par un bureau d'études qui va regarder
en face ça permet de voir les
déperditions depuis la toiture en fait
de tous les logements pouvant ce
résultat sur place exactement en fait
les particuliers donc les propriétaires
qui viennent avec un justificatif de
propriété pourront regarder en fait la
thermographie de leur logement avec le
bureau d'études qui a élaboré la
thermographie nord comme l'an passé
selon les proposés par la plateforme
repères habitat je prononce bien qu'est
ce que c'est cette plate forme donc à
lancer une plateforme de rénovation qui
est public donc c'est là le mot
important les publics donc en fait nous
on porte donc une mission de service
public ce n'est que le conseil
indépendant sur tout ce qui la
rénovation énergétique dans le logement
donc en fait on parle d'isolation on
parle de chauffage en parts de
ventilation est donc le but c'est voilà
nous on donne vraiment un regard neutre
sur tous les to les isolants tous les
systèmes de chauffage avoir les
inconvénients et les avantages
donc en fait dans ce cadre là les
particuliers peuvent s'inscrire à la
plate forme et dans ce cas ils peuvent
avoir accès à un annuaire d'artisans qui
sont nos partenaires
alors c'est un salon qui en ont plein
dans l'actualité les experts du giec
viennent de lancer une nouvelle alerte
sur le réchauffement climatique il table
sur un réchauffement de 1,5 degré entre
2030 et 2050 de est-ce que la rénovation
énergétique c'est une solution efficace
pour pour se joindre à cette lutte
contre le réchauffement
climatique oui oui du coup on fait donc
là faut savoir que le bâtiment c'est 44
% de la consommation d'énergie en france
et enfin donc qui dit consommation
d'énergie fossile dit en fait
bah co2 dans l'atmosphère du coup en
fait il y a à peu près 7 millions de bas
de maisons en france qui sont classées
est floue j'ai donc sur les sur les
classements ça veut dire que le
consommateur est six fois et demie plus
que les logements qu'on construit
actuellement qu'elle fait là il ya un
vrai potentiel qu'est ce que ça permet
concrètement aux particuliers de rénover
son habitat faire une rénovation
énergétique pense d'abord à des baises
dans des factures d'électricité
notamment
il yad'autres d'autres bienfaits le en
fait le premier bien fait ça va être le
confort parce qu'en fait par exemple si
on a une maison mal isolée
on a beau on va pouvoir chauffer la
maison à 20 vas-y remet à 20 c'est une
bonne température en fait si l'air est à
20 mai que le mur derrière moi il est à
12 ou qu'il est à 15 en fait ce que je
vais me sentir c'est pas du tout vin
mais ça va être la moyenne des deux est
du coup en fait on peut avoir un peu
consommé beaucoup beaucoup chauffage est
en fête est toujours inconfortable alors
quand on isole en fait le logement mais
du coup on va couper cette paroi froide
on va avoir une température bien plus
homogène et puis en plus on va avoir
besoin de moins d'énergie apportés à la
maison pour la chauffer puisque
l'énergie va pas ressortir par par les
murs où la toiture et si on souhaite
rénover son habitat comment on définit
son projet de rénovation énergétique a
en fait ça dépend vraiment de toutes les
maisons ça dépend de l'année de la
construction ça dépend de l architecture
ça dépend des matériaux qu'ils utilisent
et du coup en fait nous dans la mission
espaces info énergie en fait les
particuliers peuvent venir me voir et
donc ils viennent avec donc soin dpe
soit ils prennent avec des plans des
photos l'année de la construction et
nous on peut faire on peut déjà expliqué
quelles sont les priorités qu est-ce qui
est adapté sinon si on veut vraiment
avoir quelque chose de très précis on
peut faire appel à un bureau d'étude
thermique qui va venir venir chez vous
qui peuvent venir avec une caméra
thermique va en faire tous les points et
qui vont me dire voilà parlons si on
isole par l'extérieur on va faire tant
d'économie d'énergie après cette
rénovation énergétique il ya quand même
un entretien il ya des actions à
réaliser sur sur son habitat bah ça
dépend ça dépend des systèmes en fait
pas si on est sur des systèmes de
chauffage y aura toujours une
maintenance après si on est sûr
d'isolation n'ya pas d'entretien à faire
si ce n'est pas et si on isole bien faut
bien penser à ce qu'il ya un système de
ventilation puisque du coup pour bien
renouveler l'air mais
mais si non en fait ça c'est des choses
qui se font qu'il faut ça se demandent
en fait au moment dé des installations
en fait ça dépend de ce qu'on met il
aurait simplement domine dans cet
entretien le programme du salon qu'elle
est il alors donc en fait donc y aura
évidemment la thermographie aérienne qui
sera toute la journée à 10h30 hier la
visite d'une maison rénovée donc cette
maison elle a remporté le concours
maisons économes de l'année dernière
donc il ya plusieurs étapes ce sera à
montigny les personnes qui sont
intéressées aux faut s'inscrire au
préalable en fait donc sur notre site
internet
sinon à 11 heures il y aura une
conférence sur le bio climatisme en
rénovation ou comment intégrer cette
valeur leur rénovation
à 13h36 aura une conférence sur
justement comment élaborer son projet
quels sont les pièges à éviter par qu'on
commence et à quinze structures le
témoignage d'un particulier qui a rénové
sa maison de manière performante
donc c'est un architecte qui apparaît
fait ça dans sa maison du coup c'est un
témoignage qui va être assez précis
assez technique et très intéressant je
pense pour les particuliers contre
projet mais toutes ces informations on
les retrouve bien sûr sur le site
internet énergie tirée sky qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci à tiffany biseau
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes en charge de l'organisation de
ce deuxième salon est de la rénovation
énergétique
il est au programme ce dimanche à la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
et précisons le l'entrée sera gratuite
allez il va y avoir du sport tout de
suite dans ce journal
[Musique]
mais beaucoup de rencontres ce week-end
dans les yvelines pour nous éclairer sur
l'ensemble de ses résultats mais quel
ennemi d'euros bonsoir bonsoir grille on
commence tout de suite michael ce tour
d'horizon par du rugby oui grégory et
les amoureux du rugby vino attendait ce
match avec impatience la rencontre de
division honneur entre le ska rugby est
vite rick longtemps indécise a
finalement tourné à l'avantagé des
joueurs du val de marne le skies
s'incline dans les dernières minutes 22
à 18 après une belle prestation
une défaite qui fait redescendre les
joueurs de guillaume payen la deuxième
place du championnat après trois
journées on écoute les réactions au
micro de nicolas d'henri sentiment c'est
que on a bien maîtrisé le match on a
pris les devants et et on a attendu que
ça finisse en fait on a subi un peu la
fin et résultat bat caen attend on
attend la bo défendre la ligne à mon nez
ça finisse 8 voix c'est vrai que là
aujourd'hui mentalement ça fait très mal
parce que c'est notre premier match à
domicile on se disait que boudé klaus
allait être incroyable cette saison quoi
et puis en plus avec deux victoires
acteurs pour commencer on s'était mis
dans de bonnes conditions pour
accueillir une équipe comme vitry
malheureusement ce match mais un petit
coup derrière la tête mais je pense que
dès mercredi ce sera oublié et 1 dès la
semaine prochaine il faut rebondir et
oublier ça et repartir sur les bases de
la du début de la saison prochain match
pour les joueurs du sky rugby dimanche
prochain sur le terrain de vincennes
pour le choc de cette poule de division
honneur
entre le deuxième et le troisième du
championnat l'idri ont joué également un
amical ce week end la finale du
championnat de d1 de baseball est hélas
aussi malheureusement une défaite pour
les yvelinois oui oui très mauvaise
opération pour les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux en finale du championnat
de france les il y monte 1 se sont
inclinés deux fois sur les deux premiers
matchs de leur série
le score à 4-1 dans le premier match et
4 à 3 dans la seconde partie les matches
retour sont programmés le week-end
prochain
montigny-le-bretonneux devra
impérativement remporter ses trois
matches pour espérer devenir champion de
france
mais ça va être très dur les grecs on
termine ce tour d'horizon michael part
du football direction trap est ce que
les les nouvelles sont bonnes les
nouvelles sont mitigées en peut dire
dans ce championnat de r3 à trappes a
été freinée par suresnes ce week-end à
domicile
les trappistes qui restait sur trois
victoires en trois matches ont concédé
le match nul 3 partout c'est une
histoire de 3,1 grégorini mais reste
tout de même sur le fauteuil de leader
après quatre journées trappe comptent un
point d'avancé sur le second à boulogne
billancourt
merci michael on retrouve tous ces
résultats et bien d'autres encore dans
votre émission
c'est à suivre après ce journal le 7-8
sport et donc à retrouver à partir de
18h30
[Musique]
chaque lundi depuis le début de cette
saison nous vous faisons découvrir ce
territoire à cheval sur deux
départements les yvelines et l'essonne
le parc naturel régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse ce soit un départ en
observation sur la colline atypique du
parc celle de gravelle à saint lambert
des bois un reportage signé jules colis
étudier cette prairie afin de s'assurer
du développement de la biodiversité
locale
voilà une démission d'olivier marchal
chargé d'études au parc régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse nous le
retrouvons aujourd'hui sur l'un des
sites d'intérêt écologique les plus
riches du parc où sont fréquemment
effectuer des suivis afin de rendre
compte de l'état de santé de ces espaces
donc là on se trouve sur la commune de
saint lambert des bois mais sur la
prairie de la gravelle qui nous prairies
qui appartient au parc naturel régional
et on est venu en fait sur la partie
basse de la prairie
voir où en était un certain nombre de
plantes rares qui poussent ici
principalement vous voulez aller voir
les stations de l'ine great qui c'est
une petite plante en fait qui va pousser
dans les tourbières et dans les prairies
tour buzz comme on a ici et qui est une
espèce qui est protégé qu'on suit un peu
régulièrement voir ouais si elle se
maintient bien l'enjeu c'est de voir si
globalement en termes de biodiversité
sur le parc on n'a pas une perte si ces
espèces très rares il arrive à se
maintenir
et en plus ici on est sur une prairie
qui est gérée par le parc
l'idée c'est aussi d'adapter la gestion
qu'on pratique une gestion qui depuis
presque 20 ans permet à la prairie de la
gravelle de ne pas s'en ficher malgré
l'abandon du pâturage par l'agriculture
dans les années 60
outre la flore la faune est aussi
préservé par l'entretien de ces espaces
et offre ainsi de beaux foyer à ses
habitants associé à ces groupements de
plantes on va avoir beaucoup d'espèces
d'animaux aussi qu'ils sont assez
remarquables notamment des insectes
beaucoup d'insectes donc aujourd'hui on
a pu dans l'appui observer le nacre et
de la sanguisorbe qu'un papillon qui vit
sur la reine des prés sur une plante
typique de ces prairies humides c'est
vraiment un enjeu fort du parc de
rouvrir ses prairies humides dans les
fonds de vallée pour la faune pour la
flore pour les paysages aussi puisque ça
ça ouvre des perspectives des vues sur
le sur le paysage et puis c'est un rôle
aussi à jouer sur le maintien d'une
agriculture dans le parc de nombreuses
raisons qui expliquent donc les suivi
régulier de 12 sites représentant une
superficie de 60 hectares d'espacés
naturels au sein de la vallée de
chevreuse
c'est la fin du set 8 journal cette
édition et l'ensemble de ces reportages
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile atv 78 dans
un instant je vous rappelle ce
rendez-vous un nouveau numéro du 7-8
sport présentée par michael et demi
d'euros belle soirée est excellente
semaine avec tv 78
[Musique]